[موسيقى]
عرف بقدرته على صناعه الفكاهه وحمل معه
الضحك كطبق يتشاركه مع جمهور الكوميديا
العالميه لكنه ابتعد حينا لتناول جرعات
المرار بعيدا عن الشاشه وجمهورها حتى
اعتقد الكثيرون ان برندان فريزر سينتهي
لكنه عاد فجاه كنجم ذي مكانه مهمه في اهم
المحافل الفنيه فما قصته
ولد برندن جيمس فريزر عام
1968 بولايه انديانا لكنه امضى طفولته
بتورنتو حيث عمل والده موظفا بوزاره
الخارجيه الكنديه درس برندان بمدرسه
داخليه هناك ثم اكمل تعليمه في كليه كندا
العليا قبل ان يختار لنفسه طريق الفن
وينتقل الى واشنطن حيث التحق بكليه كورنيش
للفنون قبل تخرجه حاضيه برندان فريزر بان
يمثل على خشبه مسرح وست اند في اول عرض
مسرحي له كما حصل على دور صغير في فيلم
الدراما دوج فايت وخلال الفتره نفسها لعب
فريزر دورا ثانويا في البرنامج التلفزيوني
امريكا
بعد ذلك حصل على منحه للدراسه في جامعه
ومن هناك سافر الى هوليود ليبدا مسيرته
الاحترافيه مع نهايه العام
1991 لم تكن بدايه في هوليود موفقه فقد
اضطر في البدايه للتنقل بين عده مهن
واماكن حتى انه عمل بهلوانيا قبل ان يحصل
على اول فرصه حقيقيه له لكن هذه الفرصه لم
تكن بوابه الامان فيلمه الاول انسينو مان
تلقى العديد من الانتقادات كما لم تحظى
الافلام الاخرى التي ظهر فيها بشعبيه كبرى
مثل سكول تايز
ما جعله يرتكن بعيدا لفتره من الوقت امتدت
حتى عام
1997 عندما عاد الى الشاشه في فيلم
بدوري فتاه الغابه وهو الدور الذي لاقي
اشادات واسعه
قام بريندن بعدها بعده اعمال اخرى مثل
غودز اند مونسترز وداد
لكنه ارتقى للنجوميه بفضل ادائه المتميز
في ثلاثيه افلام المغامرات
عام
1999 رغم انه كاد يقتل اثناء قيامه بدور
يشنق فيه
تنقل برندن بعدها بين الادوار الكوميديه
والدراميه والاكشن كما ظهر في افلام
الخيال العلمي وقدم عددا من الاعمال
المهمه مثل
وظهر ايضا بالعديد من البرامج التلفزيونيه
الناجحه مثل دوم باتريل
وغيرها الكثير كما حصل على العديد من
الجوائز الفنيه مثل جائزه مهرجان سياتل
الدولي وجوائز مهرجان هوليود وجوائز نقابه
ممثلي الشاشه
وفيما كان يجب ان يحتفل بنجاحاته من رب
منذ عام 2003 بتجارب صعبه كوفاه والدته
وطلاقه ودخوله في حاله اكتئاب كما قام
باجراء عده عمليات جراحيه في العمود
الفقري والركبه والحبال الصوتيه فغاب عن
ادوار البطوله لمده 12 عام هذه المره قبل
ان يتصدر اسمه المشهد كنجم مرشح للاوسكار
عن ادائه في فيلم ذا ويل الذي حاز عنه
جائزه اختيار النقاد وجائزه نقابه ممثل
شاشه الامريكيه مع اعتبر بمثابه انعاش
لمسيرته اليوم لدى اسم كبير في هوليود ليس
فقط
الجمهور اطلالاته عبر شاشه الكبيره بل
وكشخصيه متحديه استطاعت تخطي الكثير من
العقبات والوقوف مجددا وكانه بنى نفسه من
جديد بعد ان كاد جهده خلال السنوات الاولى
ان يتحول لركام تنثره الرياح في ايه لحظه
[موسيقى]